.
TWENTY-TWO MIDTERMS CAN'T COME
QUICKLY ENOUGH.
HERE TO DISCUSS THE FLORIDA
GOVERNOR RON DESANTIS, GOVERNOR,
WELCOME TO THE SHELF.
APPRECIATE YOU JOINING US AGAIN.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU AS
ALWAYS.
DAN: GOVERNOR, YOU LED THE WAY
ON CORONAVIRUS SANITY THE ENTIRE
TIME I LIVED DOWN HERE.
I'M A CONSTITUENT OF YOURS,
PRESIDENT OF FLORIDA.
WHAT YOU PLAN TO DO ABOUT THESE
NEW MASK GUIDANCE FROM THE CDC?
IS THERE ANY POTENTIAL WE COULD
HAVE MANDATE BAND IN FLORIDA?
I KNOW YOU SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER BUT IS THERE A LEGISLATIVE
SITUATION TO BAN MANDATES?
>> WE'VE ALREADY DONE IT.
I SIGNED A LAW IN JUNE THAT
TERMINATES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ABILITY TO IMPOSE RESTRICTIONS
OR MANDATES ON INDIVIDUALS OR
BUSINESSES.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING IN FLORIDA
AND IT CERTAINLY WILL NOT HAPPEN
BY ME OR AT THE STATE LEVEL AS
WELL.
THE ONE AREA WHERE WE DID
NECESSARY LEGISLATE WAS WITH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SO LAST SCHOOL
YEAR SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
MASK POLICY AND OTHERS DIDN'T.
MANY PRIVATE SCHOOLS HAVE MASK
OPTIONAL AND SAME WITH CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
THE RESULTS WERE NO DIFFERENT,
THERE WERE NOT MAJOR OUTBREAKS
NO MATTER WHAT SO THIS COMING
SCHOOL YEAR, EVERY DISTRICT IN
FLORIDA PLANNED ON DOING
OPTIONAL FOR MASKS AND I THINK
THAT'S THE RIGHT POLICY.
THE CDC COMES IN AND SAYS EVERY
SINGLE PERSON IN A SCHOOL,
STUDENTS, TEACHERS AND STAFF
HAVE TO BE MASSED AT ALL TIMES,
THAT'S NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE
EVIDENCE AND NOT DATA-DRIVEN SO
YOU START TO SEE ONE OR TWO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THINK WE ARE
GOING TO FOLLOW THAT AND IMPOSE
A MASK.
I SIGNED EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
SAYS UNDER FLORIDA'S BILL OF
RIGHTS, THE PARENTS SHOULD BE
THE ONES TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY
WANT THEIR KID TO WEAR A MASK".
DO YOU BELIEVE IN THAT AND THAT
MAKES THE YOGURT, NO ONE IS
STOPPING YOU BUT THAT SHOULD NOT
BE IMPOSED ON EVERYBODY AND
WE'VE GOT TO GIVE PARENTS THE
CHOICE.
A LOT OF THESE KIDS SUFFERED
UNDER WEARING MASKS.
HIS A LOT OF HARM THAT COMES
WITH IT AND WE ARE BASICALLY
EMPOWERING THE PARENT TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
KIDS AND I THINK IN MOST
INSTANCES WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
KIDS FROM THE PARENTS
PERSPECTIVE WILL BE GO TO SCHOOL
MASK FREE.
DAN: I SORRY, I SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SPECIFIC WITH SCHOOLS AND THAT
QUESTION, YOU'RE ACCURATE WHAT
YOU HAVE DONE TO COMBAT THESE
MANDATES AND YOU HAVE SEEN EVEN
IN BLUE PLEADING COUNTIES IN
FLORIDA LIKE BROWARD WHERE THEY
ARE LOOKING AT MASK MANDATES
AGAIN, RISING GRASSROOTS EFFORTS
AND YOU KNOW VERY WELL NOT JUST
REPUBLICAN SPREAD AMONGST
DEMOCRATS, PARENT SAYING I JUST
WANT MY KID TO HAVE A NORMAL
SCHOOL YEAR.
THE MORTALITY RATE FOR KIDS WHO
DON'T HAVE COMORBIDITY OR
DISEASES, MORTALITY RATE OF THE
VIRUS IS 0%.
>> AND I THINK ONE OF THE
DANGERS I FEEL HAVING MANDATORY
MASK AT THIS TIME, GIVEN
STATISTICS YOU CITE, I THINK A
LOT OF THE BUREAUCRATIC
AUTHORITIES ARE GOING TO SAY WE
MASSED FOR COBIT, FLU IS MORE
DANGEROUS FOR KIDS THAN COBIT,
MAYBE THEY NEED TO MASK THE KIDS
EVERY FLU SEASON AND THEN IT
NEVER ENDS.
IF THE CDC HAD ITS WAY, I THINK
IT PROBABLY HAVE KIDS AND MASKS
INDEFINITELY AND IT'S NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE.
PARENTS HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS
IN REAL TIME JUST LIKE LAST
SUMMER THERE WAS SUCH HYSTERIA
BECAUSE FLORIDA WAS GOING TO GO
TO SCHOOL IN PERSON FIVE DAYS A
WEEK IN THE MEDIA WAS RAISING A
RUCKUS AND OTHER PEOPLE BUT
PARENTS ACROSS THE BOARD WANT
THE ABILITY TO SEND THEIR KIDS
TO SCHOOL AND I THINK IT'S THE
SAME THIS YEAR WITH THE MASK.
THEY WANT TO SEND THEIR KIDS AND
THEIR KIDS TO BE NORMAL AND THE
SCHOOLS ARE THE PERFECT PLACE TO
DO IT, ONE OF THE LOWEST RISK
ENVIRONMENTS WE HAVE FOR COVERED
IN THE DATA ON THAT IS VERY
CLEAR.
DAN: THE IRONY HERE IS ONE OF
THE REASONS YOU WERE ELECTED
ORIGINALLY BECAUSE OF YOUR,
YOU'VE BEEN AN OPEN ADVOCATE FOR
SCHOOL CHOICE AND MINORITY
PARENTS SUPPORTED YOU.
MANY VOTED DEMOCRAT.
I LIVE IN FLORIDA, I DON'T GET
MAPPED OUT MUCH BUT WHEN I DO,
PEOPLE KNOW I'M REPUBLICAN AND
THEY TELL ME AND SAY I'M A
DEMOCRAT BUT I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT ON THIS.
I THINK A LOT OF THEM BELIEVE
IT'S A FEAR CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE NOT USING
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS,
THEY ARE USING CASES.
IT GOOD TO KNOW THAT BUT
CANDIDLY IT'S ALMOST MEANINGLESS
STATISTICS IF VACCINATED PEOPLE
ARE SHOWING UP AS CASES BUT MANY
OF THEM ARE ASYMPTOMATIC.
>> EXACTLY AND I THINK THAT'S
THE THING, I THINK THE VACCINES
WERE SOLD AND PREVENT
INFECTIONS, I DON'T THINK THAT'S
HAPPENED.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE TESTED
POSITIVE WHO WERE VACCINATED BUT
I DO THINK IT'S HELPED
PARTICULARLY OLDER PEOPLE
AGAINST SEVERE OUTCOMES
INCLUDING DEATH SO WHAT YOU HAVE
IS YOU HAVE CASES AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE VACCINATED TESTING
POSITIVE BUT THEY HAVE AN
INCREDIBLY MILD ILLNESS.
WHY WOULD WE WANT TO SHUTDOWN
SOCIETY BECAUSE OF BACK?
I THINK NATIONWIDE WE ARE AT ONE
OF THE LOWEST POINTS IN
MORTALITY FOR THE ENTIRE
PANDEMIC AND I THINK THAT IS A
REASON WHY SO FEAR DOESN'T WORK,
I THINK PEOPLE ARE SICK OF THAT
AND SEE THAT PEOPLE HAVE AN
AGENDA AND CONSTANTLY WANT TO DO
IT MEANT YOU AND I BOTH KNOW
THERE ARE CERTAIN PEOPLE WHO
NEVER WANT THE HYSTERIA TO END
FOR THEIR OWN PURPOSES AND WE
CAN'T LET THEM WIN.
FLORIDA IS FREE AND WE PRIDE
OURSELVES ON PEOPLE BEING FREE
TO CHOOSE HOW THEY WANT TO
GOVERN THEIR AFFAIRS.
DAN: GOVERNOR DESANTIS, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR EVERYTHING YOU DO
IN TRYING TO KEEP FLORIDA F